des symboles maçonniques une lumière
tamisée
c'est dans ce temple à guyancourt que la
grande maîtresse de la grande loge
féminine de france est intervenu devant
une assemblée exclusivement féminine ça
ne veut pas dire pour autant qu'on est
contre les angles loin de là 1
on n'est pas pour autant
je veux dire des femmes qui vont dire on
vit entre femmes c'est pas ça c'est pas
ça du tout mais on a besoin puisque on
est dans une société dans laquelle on
vit en mixité du moment où on est juste
que l'on en mer eh bien il ya des
moments où on a envie de se retrouver
pas spécifiquement entre nous pour
réfléchir travailler avant de retourner
dans la société mixte créée en 1945 la
grande loge féminine de france compte
quatorze mille membres à travers le
monde qui se réunissent pour des
réflexions philosophiques ou bien encore
pour débattre de sujets de société
marie thérèse besson avait répondu à
l'invitation de la loge
saint-quentinoise concordance
c'est surtout pour faire connaître la
franc maçonnerie parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de cas il beaucoup de gens se posent des
questions dessus et puis pour si jamais
des profanes veulent venir nous
rejoindre
voilà c'est surtout pour ça actuellement
la loge concordance compte une vingtaine
de membres